On June 24th Turks go to the polls to
elect a president and Parliament six
presidential candidates are running
including incumbent Reggie taya Bear
DeLong challengers have voiced radically
different visions and some polls say
elections are too close to call
Erewhon should be in trouble Turkey's
currencies in free fall and Turkish
military operations in both Syria and
Iraq a flounder but this is matter two
days of free and fair elections in
Turkey are over Erewhon rules is a
dictator under state of emergency he's
imprisoned charismatic Kurdish candidate
sulla dean demmick louse mayor's loyal
to air21 bloc opposition campaigning
Antwon formed his own militia to beat up
challengers and a viral video shows air
tawan telling supporters prevent
opposition through voting Turkish
politicians say the margin of fraud and
cheating is at least 5 percent so any
challenger needs to win at least 55
percent and even that's no guarantee
air21 would step down there are open
questions will elections go to a second
round how many parties will enter
parliament but to consider turkey a
democracy's to believe in unicorns
there's now only one certainty
Erewhon will rule turkey until he dies
what do you think about Turkey's
election and Turkey's future let us know
in your comments also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI